[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero a 70 años de
su llegada al trono la reina isabel
segunda en inglaterra sigue siendo una
de las mujeres más destacadas del mundo
y parte fundamental para comprender el
siglo 20 y el 21 sus siete décadas como
soberana han resistido a eventos
históricos como la guerra fría la
descolonización la caída de la unión
soviética o el break shit pero también a
escándalos familiares todo esto sin
prácticamente perder popularidad pero
isabel no siempre estuvo destinada a
heredar el trono su padre jorge sexto no
tenía previsto ser monarca hasta que en
1936 aplicó su hermano mayor eduardo
octavo tío de isabel para poder casarse
con wallis simpson una divorciada
estadounidense cuya relación con eduardo
levantó mucha polémica el reinado de
jorge sexto estuvo fuertemente marcado
por la segunda guerra mundial un
conflicto que sin duda desgastó
notablemente la salud del monarca pero
que sin embargo sirvió a la princesa
isabel para prepararse a conciencia
declaro ante todos ustedes que toda mi
vida ya sea larga o corta estará
dedicado a su servicio
y al servicio de nuestra gran familia
imperial a la que todos pertenecemos
en 1952 un cáncer de pulmón terminó con
la vida de jorge sexto e isabel segunda
asumió el cargo con tan sólo 25 años un
evento histórico que todos los
británicos pudieron ver por primera vez
la coronación de la joven reina fue la
primera en ser retransmitida en
televisión el acto provocó la adulación
y admiración de millones de personas y
catapultó a la fama a isabel segunda la
nueva monarca asumió un imperio en
decadencia durante las décadas de 1950 y
isabel segunda debió hacer frente a la
descolonización de numerosos territorios
en américa áfrica asia y oceanía un
golpe duro para un imperio que años
antes había dominado una cuarta parte
del planeta la monarca británica se
centró en viajar y conocer estos
territorios con él objetivo de
fortalecer la mancomunidad de naciones
una organización que mantenía los
vínculos con reino unido que pasó de
apenas cinco miembros a 54 pero isabel
segunda no solamente enfrentó desafíos
externos también internos a finales de
la década de 1960 estalló el conflicto
norirlandés entre los unionistas
protestantes y los católicos partidarios
de sumar a irlanda del norte a la
república de irlanda esta disputa dejó
miles de muertos y puso en jaque a reino
unido que vio peligrar su estabilidad e
incluso la paz durante tres décadas
los siguientes años de su reinado
estuvieron marcados por el gobierno de
la conservadora margaret thatcher
durante este período reino unido-
enfrenta huelgas internas e isabel
segunda fue la cabeza simbólica de una
guerra colonial contra argentina por el
archipiélago de las malvinas su sintonía
con thatcher no siempre fue la mejor ya
que hubo numerosos rumores sobre su mala
relación y discrepancias sobre temas
como el aparato aunque siempre se
mostraron mucho respeto pero las mayores
controversias que rodearon a isabel 2a
fueron las familiares desde principios
de la década de 1980 la figura de la
princesa diana- esposa de su hijo el
príncipe carlos tomó mucha relevancia en
la prensa británica al igual que sus
problemas maritales con el heredero a la
corona en este contexto llegó en 1992 el
conocido como annus horribilis de la
reina tres de sus hijos se separaron y
el castillo de windsor ardió en llamas
en
1992 no es un año el que mirará hacia
atrás con absoluto placer andalusí del
ayer
en palabras de uno de mis corresponsales
más comprensivos ha resultado ser un
annus horribilis
pero su momento más complicado como
monarca fue la muerte de diana en un
accidente de tráfico en el año
1997 el fallecimiento de lady di- ocupó
todas las portadas del mundo durante
semanas la familia real se recluyó en el
castillo de balmoral en escocia durante
los días posteriores algo que afectó
significativamente a la imagen de la
reina que se vio obligada a volver a
londres para realizar el funeral de la
que fuera su nuera este cambio de
actitud ayudó a recuperar su popularidad
semanas después la llegada del nuevo
siglo trajo nuevos desafíos personales y
políticos para isabel segunda en 2002 el
año de su 50 aniversario en el trono
fallecieron su hermana margarita y la
reina madre isabel aunque los años
siguientes fueron relativamente
tranquilos para la familia real desde
2016 reino unidos se enfrenta a una gran
inestabilidad política provocada por el
break sit
aunque la salida de la unión europea
haya resultado traumática para las
instituciones británicas la monarquía ha
seguido gozando de su popularidad
la prioridad de mi gobierno es asegurar
el mejor acuerdo posible cuando el país
abandone la unión europea
y saber segunda comienza su séptima
década como reina en solitario la muerte
de su marido el duque de edimburgo
supuso un duro golpe para la monarca que
sin embargo no la ha alejado de su firme
intención de terminar el reinado cuando
fallezca tal y como prometió en su
juventud en todos estos años isabel
segunda se ha convertido en la soberana
más longeva de la historia ha visto
pasar a 14 primeros ministros y ha
conocido a las personalidades más
relevantes del planeta su persona es
historia viva del último siglo con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]